[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in peter schrager co-host of
the nfl network's good morning football
foxsports.com senior
national writer you remember where you
were on the tuck roll
college dorm emory university uh
saturday night game had the raiders
winning that one greg beaker did too
tyrone wheatley did as well i still
think uh i know exactly where i was for
that one dan where were you
any uh girls in the dorm
no come on me no
nothing
nothing me doing me flipping through
football cards and playing stratamatic
baseball that would be in college my
friend
i was a big stratimatic guy we would
play
usually at sportscenter uh after
sportscenter i'd stay and gary miller
and i would we would play stratamatic
baseball and it was awesome
loved it it's the best yeah
um you know i would rather have had
girls in the dorm room when i was in
college but you know stratimatic i guess
that filled the void there want me to
lie to you i can lie to
you're a your
you're a journalist here
um
make a case i want you to defend
uh cliff kingsbury
okay can you all right yeah sure okay
i told you back in august the cardinals
are going to make the playoffs i think
you'd say it's pretty good season if i
didn't tell you back in august that they
were going to get embarrassed in the
playoffs you might say that's no good i
thought kyle are in his worst game as a
pro i think this team got absolutely
embarrassed but
who are you replacing cliff kingsbury
within a situation would you rather have
another coach and think that that's
going to get a different outcome that
team had no shot on monday night so my
defense of kingsbury is that that was
kyler's worst game they were without
deandre hopkins and they got blown out
from go um i don't think it was an issue
of preparation i think they played that
game 10 times with what was on the field
and how that game went the rams are
going to win i've seen a lot of coaches
lose and here's the deal if cliff
kingsbury wants to be blown out or if he
wants to be fired which he very well
know could be very well very well made
could be i think there would be a line
of nfl teams that would hire him as an
offensive coordinator and i think there
would be a line twice as long if college
teams would hire him as a head coach so
my defense if it is first playoff game
they got blown out
quarterback was awful team was awful
everything was awful i don't think
you've gotta you know go say hey we need
a new coach and that's why we lost
defend mike mccarthy
hmm that's a little tougher
okay it's a little tougher i think the
the the amount of quality wins that the
cardinals had this season were
lengthy they won big games against san
francisco and won big games against the
rams they went into dallas i i picked
the niners to win this game then
beforehand and i got a lot of slack
because i was very [ __ ] sure about it
and everywhere i went was like i don't
see how the cowboys lose i certainly
don't see how mike mccarthy out coaches
kyle shanahan in the clutch and in the
clutch and the moment mattered most
we have that play at the end and i i
also look at the fake punch situation
where like all season long it felt like
it was an ongoing
verbal spat going on whether they get
along or not i'm sure they do between
mike mccarthy and fossils the special
teams coach on the sidelines in real
time and there was always something
going on and so to get the penalty right
after the fake punt just never felt like
the cowboys were buttoned up and when
you get 14 penalties that is something i
could point to the coach and say hey
it's been a plaguing them all season 127
penalties all year like at no point was
it ever cleaned up and when they needed
the wins the most against the raiders on
thanksgiving
loss against the cardinals in that big
game in week 16
lost and then you get another home game
another home game here we go dakka threw
five touchdowns against the uh the the
zombie eagles last week and we
celebrated that performance and they you
know they're down by 23 to seven to claw
back and then have that play at the end
i just never felt like this team was as
disciplined um as you'd like to see and
i think mike should come back i think
he's gonna have a shot this was great
second year and we know how those things
go and year three i think they'll be
much better but they have to clean up
the penalties but who would have thought
that their offensive line would be one
of their problems because it used to be
one of their strong points that
offensive line was not good at all
against san francisco
no it wasn't and i i i think the
pressure was on throughout and i was
even without bosa and warner for the
second half here's what i would also
point to devos samuel touched the ball
you know every time they can get it to
him and they went and had him in the
backfield had about wide receiver debo
was you know everyone in the building
knew debo it's how the niners are gonna
beat the cowboys and that's exactly what
happened
city lamb
one touch got one catch and then he had
the offside the uh the false start it's
like i know everyone's taking apart the
cowboys i look at that and say how do
you not
game plan a way to get cd lamb the ball
as many times as you can
if they could do it with debuff samuel
and you can find a way to get them in
the backfield or use them in a bubble
screen but like you shouldn't be going
to dalton schultz and cedric wilson when
the big moments that matter the most i
could critique this game a million ways
i think if the cowboys had won
um we would be an entirely different nfl
media this week it would be cowboys
mayhem there'd be so much juice there's
still is a lot of juice but in fact they
lost in such a deflating way i don't
know it just doesn't feel the same as it
would have been had they won i know you
had the rams and the chiefs in the super
bowl does that sound right
yeah september that was my pick before
this season
yeah i have uh packers in the chiefs uh
you need a do-over you comfortable with
rams chiefs
i've been asked to do do-overs when the
rams lost three straight when the chiefs
love no i'm i'm staying in there and i
think the ram okay they saved their best
game for that monday night game they
dismantled the cardinals and i know
yesterday people were like well stafford
didn't have to do much stafford went i
don't know 13 to 17 look dialed in 200
yards
looks perfect to me i i think that
they're ready to take on the right the
bucks and they've beaten them
twice in the last two years and i know
mcveigh's not scared of going into that
building i i feel like the rams might
beat the bucks this weekend he's peter
schrager co-host of no you got to be a
little bit more emphatic than they might
of course they can beat them
how about this
uh we're doing this on wednesday the
rams i might favor the ranch
i'm not making a pick yet
honestly i'm being dead seriously i
gotta see if tristan works is out there
i gotta see if ryan jensen's out there a
lot of us we will make bold predictions
and it's not even that bold it's a
three-point game it's not crazy but i
honestly don't know if the rams win if
leonard fournette's in there and if
they're two offensive linemen are in
there so i i need to see the health
status i know that's taking an easy way
out on a win but
better story if the bills advance or the
chiefs advance
ooh
better story i think is the bills and
it's like i i think it's it's about josh
allen really and how he's had to chip
away year after year per year and then
this is the team that got the best of
them last year and kept him away um i
think it's the bills i think last week
they finally buried
you know one big
dragon master that they've had to deal
with and that's the patriots for 20
years in their division and the chiefs
have gotten the best of them in the
playoffs last year in arrowhead i think
if the bills are due like i was thinking
about los angeles for the super bowl if
either one of these two fan bases do go
on and beat the afc uh championship game
contender from the titans bengal i think
it'd be really cool i think you're going
to see a lot of build fans travel to los
angeles it's a warm weather city and
it's not going to be like a small market
team i feel like those fans come out
and then of course the chiefs fans show
up wherever they go so i i think both of
these teams are great stories obviously
the home story line and hey we're not
done yet um but i think buffalo this is
kind of feeling like a destiny miracle
season and if they get their super bowl
in los angeles that's pretty cool let's
look at the options for the steelers to
replace ben roethlisberger
oh by the way tj watt was with us
yesterday he said i still don't know if
he's retiring he never told us anything
but let's assume ben is done
so if you're mike tomlin what's plan a
and i've heard
a lot of rumors and a lot i don't i
think that i don't think draft is the
way to go with this veteran locker room
with the minkos and with the watts and
then with tim hayward i'm not sure
they're going to attend the ranks of
rookie i don't know if haskins has shown
enough this year and i certainly don't
think mason rudolph has in the past few
years so i would look at a veteran
quarterback i really would i'm not
saying it's necessarily rogers or wilson
but there is that next here and you're
looking at names who might be available
and it could be garoppolo it could be
cousins it could be uh jameis winston it
could be a lot of names but i think i
would look at that that that it could be
that
you know it could be cousins or
garoppolo as i said but it also could be
guys that are maybe younger and it's a
trubisky type or someone like that that
hasn't had that opportunity to ever you
know start this season but is still
laying in the weeds and waiting to go so
i look at all the veteran quarterbacks
but i don't know if they're going to be
able to land
russell or aaron rodgers or desean
watson wow
well i wonder how this all plays out but
it feels like if rogers leaves
they're going to make sure he goes to an
afc team if russell leaves they're going
to make sure he goes to an afc team do
you think that sounds logical
sounds about felt right to me it doesn't
look like they want to face either one
of those guys in the playoffs from both
sides i'm feeling more and more that
rogers and wilson who if you asked me
week 10 uh you know which teams are
going for we could do the whole denver
and carolina and miami conversation
more and more i'm not sure either one of
those guys is gone just yet and i i
think we're gonna see how the next few
weeks play out remember russell said
what he said on your show last year
around super bowl week i think it was
and that's when this whole thing started
um ken norton was fired yesterday i'd
keep an eye on what's going on in
seattle next series because anyone who
tells you that they're plugged into
seattle that might have been the case
when you know paul allen was in charge
and pete carroll was infallible and all
this stuff like no one talks to jody
allen the owner right now she's the
sister of uh of paul allen and she's
running the show right now and whether
there have been conversations with pete
and john schneider and all those guys
and russell that she's been having i
don't think the media has plugged into
that so i'd say let's give it a couple
of weeks here before we immediately
assume russell's going or staying
you know somebody who gathers
information uh how often do you question
the person who's giving you that
information as to why they're giving you
that information
i think i'm pretty good hit rate i know
i've had a couple misses but i would
like to think that i'm not one who's
easily led down the wrong road for
personal benefit because that'll burn me
forever i don't think i'm going anywhere
and if you if you burn me i'm pretty
pretty clean with it that hey i don't
want to hear you know the stuff that i
get a lot of smoke screens is the nfl
draft and that's kind of understandable
and hey we're not going to mention this
guy when we talk to you about who we
like and then they end up taking him i'm
like hey you didn't mention him yeah
because he wanted them but this kind of
stuff where it's uh coaches being fired
and coaches getting hired i think
everyone's pretty spot on with me and i
i usually am pretty accurate
well it's like i got roughed up by a guy
with the nfl network when i'd mentioned
nobody was interested in carson wentz
and nobody was calling the eagles and
that person's philadelphia-based so
probably wants to play nice with the
eagles even though we know
carson went nobody wanted carson wentz
other than you know it was the colts and
that was about it
i don't even know if the colts still
want him pete
yeah and you saw what uh chris ballard
their gm had to say it wasn't a rousing
hey without but hey they're tied onto
them now for three more years they'd
have to do some really really
creative creative and uh to your point i
think after this year after another year
of it and him not delivering in the
final two weeks of the season i really
don't know if there's a market for
cartoons especially at the salary that
he has
all right three defenders all time from
any teams
now any position
you could have three from whatever
generation you want
but uh tell me who and why you would
have
all right can i give you can i give a
question though is it am i taking any
player from any individual season or is
it the breadth of their career because
they're guys that had great seasons
individually that i would say i can't
say in good faith i would take the the
career or are you saying just take any
three you have to
get them their entire career they stay
healthy their entire career
i'm going right across my defensive line
and this is no disrespect to champ
bailey or dion
or lawrence taylor or derek thomas but
i'm going bruce smith on one end i'm
going aaron donald in the middle and i'm
going reggie white right next to him
uh all you need is a three-man rush in a
situation like that peter good good luck
good luck getting a pass off with those
three it doesn't push it from the inside
reggie inside or outside and then versus
smith who i think is criminally
underrated when we talk about great
defensive players like everyone brings
up lt and everyone brings up reggie but
like bruce smith and derek thomas we're
right up there with those guys every
single student in the same generation it
doesn't matter who my secondary is if
i've got those three guys up front you
pick
dennis can be a secret it's a second day
we're good we'll we'll roll with that
yeah i having seen lawrence taylor in
his prime and i
like
just the image of of watching him play
what he did and how teams game i don't
know if there's
i don't know if team's game plan for a
defensive player like they did
lawrence taylor
he changed the nfl i don't know how many
other defensive players you can say he
changed the nfl but
you know the way tight ends you know
what joe gibbs did you got to have
another guy you got a chip you got a
tight end's got to help the tackle like
lawrence taylor
changed the game with his style
and and the accolades are there when you
talk about the defensive player of the
year as a rookie talk about an mvp from
the defensive spot 1986 the only player
to do it um in the last three or four
decades i will be honest though and it's
not that unbiased like
like i told you i was in college during
the tuck roll game so do the math i just
missed peak lt i got 1990 lt where he
has the big strip of roger craig and and
the giants are a great team i got that
the lighter state is like watching in
person reggie white dismantle defense
offensive lines and then watching what
aaron donald does in the real time and
then knowing that over 20 years bruce
smith compiled all those sacks and just
dominated weekend week out i'm going
with those three and it's nothing
against lt i just i wasn't alive and i
wasn't watching when he was doing what
he's doing in the early 80s give me the
surprise result this weekend
huh the surprise result i think is uh
san francisco potentially going in there
and bullying the packards around i'm not
sure if i'm picking him yet but i know
kyle shanahan by no means is scared of
uh coaching staff of mike of matt
lafleur joe barry and nathaniel hackett
three guys he's worked with before and
they have gotten the best of rogers in
playoff games in the past um
i i would not be surprised if this was
one of those where
sanchez comes in and just it's a low
scoring game and rogers has to pull a
rabbit out of his hat and bosa or warner
makes a play if they're healthy and they
get it done
what do you think the fallout would be
at the packers loss this weekend
tune in on monday
sometimes sometimes when uh
the world is burning it's good for
raining so i don't know let's see we'll
just watch thank you buddy great to talk
to you
thank you that's peter schrager co-host
of uh nfl network's good morning
football you can follow peter at uh
p shreds the show airs monday through
friday at 7 a.m eastern